I'm really interested in understanding
the military concept and I've listened
to you a number of times describe that
and I've seen it in programs in shows
the military how can it how it shapes
minds to a point where that individual
will put the most precious thing their
life on the line for the partner how can
we create that in our organizations not
in the timeframe of years but in the
timeframe of weeks and months laying the
military yeah so let's answer those
questions in Reverse so one of the
things that I I have deep admiration for
the military and the admiration I have
for the military is the exact same love
and admiration I have for artists is
because they both undertook their their
their paths knowing that they weren't
going to get rich and felt like it was a
calling and we're willing to sacrifice
to advance this thing whatever it is and
be a part of something so to me it's the
same it's the same love and the thing
that I noticed immediately when I
started hanging out with folks in
uniform is you and I have colleagues and
co-workers they have brothers and
sisters
they literally refer to the people they
work with as brothers and sisters and
the relationship is one of brother and
sister which is they may fight but they
you you try and attack my brother or
sister you got to go through me they
love each other love is the word they
were use that the Marine Corps calls
them the intangibles right that what
makes the Marine Corps strong are the
intangibles what they mean is empathy
love devotion these these these mushy
words and you're asking me a question
like how do we do it in weeks and months
it's it's it's a these are human beings
we're talking about right so that's like
asking me can I give you advice so that
you can fall in love in a matter of
weeks instead of having to do this whole
like getting to know
being vulnerable
I got no app for that it's a slow bloody
process sometimes you get lucky and you
have a meeting of the minds and you have
shared values and it goes a little
quicker but even though we get really
excited we jump in the relationship
three months where they were like what
was I thinking right there is no way to
speed up it takes more than a week but
if you've been doing something for seven
years and you don't love it maybe it's
wrong right I just don't know where it
happens so what I do know is that the
way you build trust inside an
organization is the exact same way you
fall in love right which is you devote
yourself to the care of another human
being sometimes at the sacrifice of your
own interests it means when the person
you love comes home from work and they
said I had a terrible day and you had an
amazing day you don't say a word about
your amazing day at all and you sit
there and listen with love and empathy
to their horrible day as opposed to
waiting for your turn to speak you know
it means that you wake up in the morning
you say good morning to them before you
check your phone it's the little things
it means you learn to listen and make
them and listening is real easy means
you you make the other person feel heard
so if you can go learn all of those
things on how to make a friend and how
to fall in love
now go do all of those things at work
then when somebody walks in two hours
goes oh [ __ ] my day
you go what's happening and you listen
so they feel heard don't get them advice
don't fix anything just listen right
when they tell you how awful it is say
that sucks
tell me more right it's the same thing
it's the exact same thing and I promise
you I promise you you will build those
relationships will you will fall in love
with the people you work with and you
will call them brothers and you will
call them sisters and they were the same
they will say the same of you so it's
that's how you do that and by the way
the military doesn't do it in 13 weeks
what they do is they create a foundation
for it in 13 weeks but it takes time for
those relationships to truly form
[Music]
[Music]